[Applaudissements]
le premier le seul le vrai paradis c'est
Paris quelle est la terre que Moïse
promis c'est
Paris sa force est tellement vitale que
dans cette capitale tous les plus petits
despêchés sitô devienent cap qu'est-ce
que d'abord saint VI
promis qui a converti le bon roi
Henri lui seul V toutes les messes lui
seul tient toutes les promesses moi je
vous comme il n rien de mieux que
Paris votre fir maman c'est très gentil
c'est charmant plein
d'agrément on y sent flotter une odeur
de sainteté de propreté c'est bien on n
dans le bleu on a des conf tout ce qu'on
veut c'est très ép le ciel a cependant
et
Cendant je compte sur vous monsieur Lux
mademoiselle
ver et allons-y les G et vous aussi
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui possède
[Musique]
l'opraies promenade
idé
pouraver rivis
ave le
cielele
GR sont en poudre de riz c'est
par qui rend les femmes si belles et m
au fond de leur Brunelle ce charmin fini
ce sourire rqui ne cherchez pas c'est
Paris
merci